If you're looking for affordable language lessons,
give "italki" a try.
Cut out the middleman and connect
directly with native teachers internationally.
Right now you can buy one lesson and get one free.
Click the link in the description box.
Hello everyone. Welcome to the Langfocus channel
and my name is Paul.
Today's topic is the Afrikaans language.
A couple of weeks ago I released a video on
the Dutch language which you can find right here
This is kind of a follow-up to that video
because Afrikaans is a descendant of Dutch.
That means that just like Dutch,
Afrikaans is a West-Germanic language.
Afrikaans has a total of about 7.1 million native
speakers, with 6.8 five million of those in South Africa.
That's about 13.5 % of the South African population.
That makes it the third most widely spoken language
in South Africa and it's the majority language
in the western half of the country.
That means Northern Cape and Western Cape provinces.
It's the native language of about 61% of white South Africans
and it's the native language of more than 3/4 of
"colored" South Africans, about 3.4 million people.
In South Africa, the term "colored" means
people of mixed racial background.
I didn't choose that term myself.
It's also the native language of 4.6%
of Asian South Africans.
It's also the native language of 1.5% of black
South Africans, that's about 600,000 people.
And there are 10 to 15 million second language
speakers in South Africa.
In Namibia, it's the native language of 10 or 11% of
people, including 60% of the white population.
It's also widely used as a lingua franca and
most people can speak it as a second or third language.
So how did the story of Afrikaans begin?
Dutch-speaking settlers arrived
in Southern Africa in the year 1652,
when the Dutch East India company set up a resupply
station at Cape Town for its ships traveling to
the indian subcontinent and to Southeast Asia.
Their goal was to get fresh water, food
and other supplies for their long sea journeys.
When the local Khoisan people - people who speak
Khoisan languages - were unwilling to meet
the trade demands of the Dutch East India Company,
the company drove them out of the area into the inland
and replace them with European settlers and with slaves
from other parts of Africa.
Most of the farmers, who were known as "Boers", were
former laborers of the Dutch East India company,
and most of them were Dutch.
But some of them were French or German too.
Upset with the conditions placed upon them
by the Dutch East India Company,
the European settlers began expanding inlands, so
they could farm outside of the area controlled
by the company.
The Dutch East India Company wanted to prevent
this inland expansion, so they outlawed the expansion,
ended European immigration
and increase the number of slaves instead.
Some of the slaves were brought from the Indian subcontinent
and from present-day Malaysia and Indonesia.
Britain seized control of the Cape Colony in 1815
and began to import British settlers.
The British eventually took steps to eliminate slavery
and to put every restrictions on the Boer farmers.
Large numbers of Boers migrated further inland
to escape British rule setting up their own communities
and encountering various native African communities
along the way.
After a series of conflicts with the British called
the "Boer Wars", South Africa became a unified
British colony until its independence in 1961.
But this is Langfocus. We're supposed to focus
on languages. Why is all this history important?
Well, it is to help you imagine the conditions under
which the language spoken by those Dutch settlers
changed and eventually became Afrikaans.
Exactly how Afrikaans developed is a highly debated
subject with some people insisting that
it's a natural direct descendant of Dutch,
while other people insist that it's actually
a creole language that arose when slaves
and laborers attempted to learn Dutch.
If you're not sure what creole languages are, you can have
a look at my video on pidgin and creole languages right here.
Nobody knows exactly what process has caused
Afrikaans to develop, but it's unlikely that either
of those two theories is 100% true.
In the early years of the Cape Colony, there was
a continuous stream of Dutch-speaking immigrants,
as well as other Europeans who learned
Dutch as a second language.
There were also many local speakers of Khoisan
languages who learned Dutch as a second language.
and there were also African and Asian slaves
who learned Dutch as a second Language.
Local Africans and slaves most likely spoke
a Dutch-based pidgin language at some point.
Typically a creole language arises
when a pidgin language becomes
the native language of the next generation.
Usually without a lot of influence from speakers
of the original standard language,
for example slave owners or colonial settlers.
But, in the case of Afrikaans, there was always
extensive contact with native speakers of Dutch.
More specifically, the emerging dialect called "Cape Dutch"
On top of that, Standard Dutch (and not Cape Dutch)
was the language that was taught in schools.
Both of these factors would help Cape Dutch remain
relatively similar to standard Dutch.
So even if Afrikaans is a creole language,
it's more like a partial creole or a semi creole language.
2 creole languages that I'm familiar with are Tok Pisin
and Bislama, which are spoken in Melanesia
and they are English-based creoles.
Both of those languages consists of
mainly English vocabulary but with the syntax,
grammar and phonology of an Oceanic language.
They're essentially new languages
that got their vocabulary from English.
Afrikaans is not like that. Its grammar became simplified
but the syntax of the language is basically the same
as Dutch and it's phonology is also close to Dutch.
So it seems that Afrikaans developed from a form of Dutch
that was influenced by second language speakers,
rather than a completely new creole language
featuring Dutch vocabulary.
That's my personal assessment but I'm sure
some people will disagree, and that's fine.
Afrikaans continued to develop until it was legally
recognized as its own language in 1925.
So how is Afrikaans different from Dutch?
Loanwords
The vocabulary of Afrikaans was  influenced
by the various languages that it came in contact with.
For example, Malay. The word "amper " meaning "almost",
comes from the Malay word "hampir"
The word "baie" meaning "much"
comes from the Malay word "banyak".
Portuguese. The word "combers" meaning "blanket"
comes from the portuguese word "cobertor"
The word "kraal" meaning "cattle enclosure"
comes from the portuguese word "curral".
We have a similar word "corral" in English.
Khoisan languages :
the words for a lot of things in the local African
environment came from Khoisan languages.
For example, plants & animals.
This animal is called the khoedoe.
But the overwhelming majority
of Afrikaans vocabulary is Dutch.
More than 90% or as high as 95%.
Spelling
Afrikaans underwent some spelling simplifications
to make the written language more reflective
of the spoken language.
I won't mention all the changes
but here are some examples.
The Dutch digraph "ij" pronounced "..."
became just a "y" in Afrikaans.
So we have the Dutch word "prijs",
which is spelt like this in Afrikaans "prys".
But Dutch words ending "lijk", pronounced as "..."
are spelt "lik". And that's a more accurate reflection
of the real pronounciation.
Dutch "tion" becomes "sion" in Afrikaans.
So we have the Dutch word "nationaal"
and the speaking and the spelling in Afrikaans.
These Dutch diphtongs which are actually pronounced
identically by many Dutch speakers all became spelt "ou"
in Afrikaans.
So the Dutch words "vrouw" en "dauw"
are spelt like this in Afrikaans: "..."
There are also some other spelling changes
that represent new pronunciation in Afrikaans.
For example, Afrikaans merge the Dutch consonnants
"z" and "s" to a single sound spelt "s"
So the Dutch word "zorg" became "sorg" in Afrikaans.
A similar phonetic change can also be found
in the Northern Netherlands but it is not represented
in writing. Only in speech.
Afrikaans also merge together the Dutch sounds
represented by "ch" and "g" to a single sound spelt "g".
And again, a similar merging also be happened in the Netherlands but not in spelling, only in sound.
In Afrikaans, when the g sound is preceded by an "s",
it is written as "sk". So we have the Dutch word "school"
and the Afrikaans word "skool".
Between 2 vowels, the Dutch "g" and "v" consonnants
are omitted in Afrikaans.
Look at these Dutch words "hoger", "regen"
And now the Afrikaans equivalents : "hoër", "reën"
Notice that the second vowel requires a diacritic so that we know to pronounce these as 2 separate vowels and not as 1 diphthong.
There are many more spelling changes but
those are a few examples to give you a sense
of how things changed.
Verbs
The verb system in Afrikaans
is quite simple compared to Dutch.
First of all, the simple past isn't used,
except for 8 basic verbs.
For all other verbs, the perfect tense is used instead, which is also possible in Dutch too.
So here is the Dutch sentence meaning "I watched".
And now here is the Afrikaans sentence.
So notice that we used the perfect tense
in Afrikaans, because there is no past tense.
But this Afrikaans sentence is similar to
the Dutch perfect tense sentence.
But notice that the way the past participle
is formed is a little different.
Also notice that the form
of the verb for "have" is different.
These are both the present tense form
of the verb meaning to have.
The one in Dutch is conjugated for first person singular.
But Afrikaans verbs don't change according to personal number
So the Dutch verb will change in other sentences
but, in Afrikaans, it will always be "het".
There is also no pluperfect tense in Afrikaans.
Pluperfect  is like "had watched".
Instead the perfect form would be used
So let's just jump into a few more example sentences
and look at these differences as well as some others.
The next sentences mean "I talked to my children"
In Dutch: "..."
and in Afrikaans: "..."
First of all, notice the difference in personal pronouns.
In Dutch "ik" and in Afrikaans: "ek"
and then notice the different forms
of the verb meaning "to have"
The next word "met" means "with"
and next, we can see that the possessive pronouns are
different. In Dutch "mijn" and in Afrikaans "my".
Next is the word for "children" but
notice that the plural form is different.
Notice that the word order is exactly the same
and that the second verb goes at the end in Afrikaans,
which is the same as in Dutch
and also the same as in German.
The next sentences mean:
"Did you have a good New Year?"
First, in Dutch: "..."
and in Afrikaans: "..."
In English, it's like :
"have you a good new year had?"
Again, we see the different forms
of the verb meaning "to have".
Then we see the different spelling
of the personal pronoun "jij" meaning "you".
Then, we have the indefinite article
which has been shortened in Afrikaans.
Then notice that the word for good is slightly different.
Then, after that, notice the slight difference
in the words for "a new year".
And finally, the past participle of the verb meaning
"to have" is the same in both sentences.
Now let's look at a similar sentence
but with a little change.
This one means: "Did he have a good new year?".
In Dutch: ...  and in Afrikaans: "..."
Look at the first word and notice
that the Dutch verb conjugation changes.
This is the third person singular form of the verb
but the verb form stays the same in Afrikaans.
And next, we see that the personal pronoun "hij"
meaning "he" is spelled differently.
After that, the rest of the words are the same
as in the sentence is up above.
The next sentences mean "we will live, we will die"
In Dutch: "..." and in Afrikaans : "..."
Notice here that the subject pronoun for "we" is different.
In Dutch, the subject pronoun is "we"
but the object pronoun (similar to "us") is "ons".
In Afrikaans, "ons" is both the subject
and the object pronoun.
Next, notice that the future tense in Dutch
is formed using "zullen" plus the infinitive.
In Afrikaans, it's formed by using "sal" plus the verb.
And there really isn't an infinitive in Afrikaans,
there's just one single verb form.
This part here is the same as the present tense form.
So we can see that there are some differences
between Dutch and Afrikaans but generally,
the vocabulary is very similar
and probably very easy to recognize once you're
aware of those general differences.
And the word order is basically the same.
So how well can Dutch-speakers and
Afrikaans-speakers understand each other.
The answer to this question depends on who
you ask but generally they seem to be
mutually intelligible to a moderate level,
with Afrikaans speakers being able to understand Dutch
better than Dutch speakers can understand Afrikaans.
There are a couple of important factors in intelligibility.
One of them is accent.
I've heard from a few Dutch people and from a few
Afrikaans people that they can understand
certain speakers of the other language very well
but other speakers are harder to understand.
And that might be because certain Dutch dialects
have pronunciation that is more similar
to Afrikaans than others.
And there are also a lot of second language speakers
of Afrikaans whose accent might be difficult
for a native Dutch speakers to understand.
Another factor is register.
Register means the level of formality used.
Now, if the speakers of both languages use
the standard formal variety of their language
and they don't use any local variations or slang,
then they'll probably understand each other much better.
Formal speech basically resembles the written language
and the speakers of either language can basically
understand the other one when it's written.
A common question that I see written on the internet is
"Should I learn Afrikaans before learning Dutch?"
"Would that help me to learn Dutch later on?"
I would say that that's probably a bad idea to learn
Afrikaans just because you want to learn Dutch later.
It probably would end up confusing you
when you learn Dutch later on,
because Dutch is similar to Afrikaans
but more complex.
I would say that the best reason to learn Afrikaans would be
because you have a deep cultural interest in South Africa
and you want to spend some time in that country.
Or in Namibia.
So the question of the day for speakers
of Afrikaans and Dutch.
How well can you guys understand each other?
Leave your comments and your experiences down below.
And for everyone else:
I don't have a question of the day. So, why don't you ask
a question to the Afrikaans and Dutch speakers?
That sounds good!
Be sure to follow Langfocus
on Facebook Twitter and Instagram.
And I want to say thanks to all of my patreon supporters
for continuing to make Langfocus possible.
Thank you for watching and have a nice day!